i would encourage people to conjure up
their vision of paradise and the future
can potentially be like that only much
much better
welcome to the future of life institute
podcast i'm lucas perry
today we have a particularly unique
episode with berlin-based dj
and producer sam barker as well as with
david pierce
and right now you're listening to sam's
track paradise engineering on his album
utility we focus centrally on the fy
podcast
on existential risk the other side of
existential risk
is existential hope this hope reflects
all of our dreams
aspirations and wishes for a better
future for me
this means a future where we're able to
create material abundance
eliminate global poverty end factory
farming
and address animal suffering evolve our
social
and political systems to bring greater
well-being to everyone
and more optimistically create powerful
aligned artificial intelligence that can
bring about
the end of involuntary suffering and
help us to idealize the
quality of our minds and ethics if we
don't go extinct
we have plenty of time to figure these
things out
and that brings me a lot of joy and
optimism
whatever future seems most appealing to
you these visions are a
key component to why mitigating
existential risk is so important
so in the context of covid19
we'd like to revitalize existential hope
and this podcast is aimed at doing that
as a part of this podcast sam was kind
enough to create a guest mix for us
you can find that after the interview
portion of this podcast and can find
where it starts by checking the
timestamps
i'll also release the mix separately a
few days after this podcast goes live
some of my favorite tracks of sam's not
highlighted
in this podcast are look how hard i've
[Music]
tried
[Music]
[Music]
and neuron collider
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you enjoy sam's work and music
featured here
you can support or follow him at the
links in the description
he has a bandcamp shop where you can
purchase his albums
i grabbed a vinyl copy of his album
debiasing from there
as for a little bit of background on
this podcast sam barker
who produces electronic music under the
name barker
has albums with titles such as
de-biasing
and utility i was recommended to listen
to these
and discovered his album utility is
centrally inspired by david pierce's
work
specifically the hedonistic imperative
utility has track titles
like paradise engineering experience
machines
gradients of bliss hedonic treadmill and
wireheading
so being a fan of sam's music production
and
david's philosophy and writing i wanted
to bring them together to explore the
theme of existential hope
and sam's inspiration for his albums and
how david fits into all of it
many of you will already be familiar
with david pierce
he is a friend of this podcast and a
multiple time guest
david is a co-founder of the world
transhumanist association
rebranded humanity plus and is a
prominent figure within the
transhumanism movement in general
you might know him from his work on the
hedonistic imperative
a book which explores our moral
obligation to work towards the abolition
of suffering in all sentient life
through technological intervention
finally
i want to highlight the 80 000 hours
podcast with
rob whiblen if you like the content on
this show
i think you'll really enjoy the topics
and guests on rob's podcast
his is also motivated by and
contextualized in an effective
altruism framework and covers a broad
range of topics related to the world's
most
pressing issues and what we can do about
them if that sounds of interest to you
i suggest checking out episode number 71
with ben todd on the ideas of 80 000
hours
and episode number 72 with toby ord
on existential risk and with that here's
my conversation with dave and sam
as well as sam's guest mix
for this first section i'm basically
interested in
probing the releases that you already
have done sam
and exploring them and your inspiration
for the track titles and the soundscapes
that you've
produced some of the background and
context for this
is that much of this seems to be
inspired by and related to
david's work in particular the
hedonistic imperative
so i'm at first curious to know sam
how did you encounter david's work and
what does it mean for you
david's work was sort of arriving in the
middle of a sort of a series of
realizations and kind of coming from a
starting point of being quite
disillusioned with music and a little
bit disenchanted with the vagueness and
the terminology and the imprecision of
the whole thing
i think part of me has always wanted to
be some kind of scientist but i've ended
up at perhaps not the opposite end but
quite far away from it
could you explain what you mean by
vagueness and imprecision i suppose the
classical idea of what making music is
about is a lot to do with sort of
western idea of individualism and about
self-expression
and about i don't know there's this
romantic idea of artists
having these frenzied creative bursts
that give birth to these wonderful
things
that it's some kind of struggle and i
just was feeling
super disillusioned with all of that and
around that time
2014 or 15 i was also reading a lot
about social media
reading about behavioral science trying
to sort of figure out what was going on
in this
arena and how people are being pushed in
different directions by this
algorithmic system of information
distribution so that kind of got me into
the sort of behavioral science side of
things like the addictive
part of the reward variable ratio reward
schedule
with likes and it's like a free dopamine
dispenser kind of thing
and so this was kind of getting me into
reading about behavioral science
and cognitive science and
it was given me a lot of clarity but not
much more sort of inspiration
it was basically like music dance music
especially
is a sort of complex behavioral science
and you do this and people do that
and it's all deeply ingrained you know i
sort of imagine the dj is a sort of
skinner box operator pulling
puppet strings and making people behave
in different ways and music producers
are kind of
designing clever programs using
punishment and reward
or suspense and release and controlling
people's behavior
the whole thing felt super pushy and not
a very inspiring conclusion but
looking at the problem from a cognitive
science point of view was the
framework that helped me to understand
what the problem was in the first place
so
this kind of problem of being
manipulative
so behavioral science was kind of saying
what we can make people do and cognitive
psychology is sort of figuring out why
people do that
that was my entry point into cognitive
psychology and that was kind of the
basis for
de-biasing there's always been a sort of
a parallel for me between
what i make and my state of mind and
when i'm in a more positive state i tend
to make things i'm happier with
and so on getting to the bottom of what
tricks were i suppose with dance music
but i kind of understood implicitly but
i just wanted to figure out
why things worked i sort of came to the
conclusion it was to do with
the collection of biases we had the
confirmation bias and the illusion of
truth effects and the mere exposure
effects and these things that i like the
guardians of 4-4 supremacy because dance
music can be pretty
repetitive and we describe it sometimes
in really aggressive
terminology and it's a psychological
kind of
interaction so cognitive psychology was
leading me to kaplan's
law of the instrument the law of the
instrument
says that if you give a small boy a
hammer he'll find that everything
he encounters requires pounding and i
thought that was a good metaphor
the idea is that we get so used to using
tools in a certain way that
we lose sight of what it is we're trying
to do we act in the way that the tool
instructs us to do so i thought
what if you take away the hammer and
that became a metaphor
for me in the sense that david clarified
in terms of pain reduction
that we sort of put these painful
elements into music in a way
to give this kind of contrast this
hedonic contrast
but we don't really consider that that
might not be uh necessary and what
happens when we
abolish these sort of negative elements
are the results somehow released from
this
process that was sort of the point up
until
discovering the hedonistic imperative i
think what i was needing at the time was
a sort of
framework so i had the idea that music
was decision making
to improve the results you have to ask
better questions make better decisions
and you can
make some progress looking at the
mechanics of that from a psychology
point of view
what i was sort of lacking was a purpose
to frame my decisions around
i sort of had the idea that music was a
sort of a balance carrier
if you like and that it could be tooled
towards
a sort of a greater purpose than just
making people dance which was
for de-biasing the goal really it was
make people dance but
don't use the sort of cues the deeply
ingrained cues that people are used to
and see if that works what was
interesting was
how broadly it was accepted this first
ep
and there was all kinds of djs playing
it and
techno ambien electro all sorts of
different
styles and it reached a lot of people it
was as if
taking out the most functional element
made it more functional
and more broadly appealing and that was
the entry point to utilitarianism
there was sort of an accidentally
utilitarian act in a way
to sort of try and maximize the pleasure
and minimize the pain
i suppose after landing in
utilitarianism and searching for
some kind of framework for a sense of
purpose in my
work the hedonistic imperative was
probably the most radical
optimistic take on the system firstly it
put me in a sort of
mindset where it granted permission to
explore sort of utopian ideals because i
think the idea of pleasure is
a little bit frowned upon in the art
world i think the art world turns its
nose up at such a direct
cause and effect the idea that producers
could sort of be
paradise engineers of sorts or the
precursors to paradise engineers
that we could have a role in or that we
almost certainly would have a role
in a kind of sensory utopia of the
future
so there was this kind of permission
granted you can be optimistic you can
enter into your work with good
intentions it's okay to see music as a
tool to increase
overall net well-being in a way that was
kind of a guiding
idea for my work in the studio i'm
trying these days to put more things
into the system to
make decisions in a more conscious way
at least where
it's appropriate to this sort of notion
of
reducing pain and increasing pleasure
was the sort of question i would ask
at any stage of decision making did this
thing that i did
serve those ends if not take a step back
and try a different approach
there's something else to be said about
the way you sort of explore this
utopian world without really being
bogged down
like you handle the objections in such a
confident way
i called it a zero gravity world of
ideas
and i wanted to bring that zero gravity
feeling to my work
and to see that technology can solve any
problem in this sphere
anything's possible all the obstacles
are just imagined
because we fabricate these worlds
ourselves
these are things that were really
instructive for me as an artist
that's quite an interesting journey so
from the lens of understanding cognitive
psychology and human biases
was it that you were seeing those biases
in dance music itself and if so
what were those biases in particular on
both sides in the way it's produced in
the way it's received
there's sort of an unspoken acceptance
you're playing a set and you take a kick
drum out and that signals to people
to perhaps be alert to the lighting
engineer they'll maybe
raise the lights a little bit and
everybody knows that the music is going
into a sort of a breakdown which is
going to
end in some sort of climax and then at
that point the kick drum comes back in
and we all know this pattern it's really
difficult to
understand why that works without
referring to things like cognitive
psychology
or behavioral science so what does the
act of de-biasing
the reception and production of music
look like and due to the music and its
reception
the first part that i could control was
what i put into it so
the experiment was whether a d biased
piece of dance music could
perform the same functionality or
whether it really relies on these deeply
ingrained cues
without wanting to sort of pat myself on
the back it kind of succeeded in its
purpose it was sort of proof that this
was a worthy concept
you used the phrase earlier 4-4 for
people who are not into dance music that
just means
a kick on each beat which is ubiquitous
in
much of house and techno music you've
removed that
for example in your album debiasing what
are other things that you
changed from your end in the production
of de-biasing to
de-bias the music from normal dance
music structure
so it was informing the structure of
what i was doing so much that i wasn't
working so much on a
grid where you have predictable things
happening
it's a very highly formulaic and
structured thing
and that's all keys into the expectation
and this confirmation bias that people
i think get some kind of kick from when
the predictable happens they say yep
there you go
i knew that was going to happen and
that's a little dopamine rush but i
think it's a sort of a cheap trick
and so i guess i was trying to get the
tricks out of it in a way
and so figuring out what they were and
trying to reduce or eliminate them
was the process for devising so that's
quite interesting
and meaningful i think like let's just
take trap music
i know exactly how trap music is gonna
go it has this build up and drop
structure
it's basically universal across all
dance music progressive house in the
2010s was also exactly like this
yeah what else dubstep of course
same exact structure everything is
totally predictable
i feel like i know exactly what's going
to happen having listened to electronic
music for
over a decade yeah and it works i think
it's a tried and tested formula and it
does the job
but when you're trying to imagine states
beyond just getting a little kick from
knowing what was going to happen that's
the place that i was trying to get to
really so then after the release of
de-biasing in 2018 which was a
successful attempt at
serving this goal and mission you then
discovered the hedonistic imperative by
david pierce
and kind of leaned into consequentialism
it seems
yeah and then in 2019 you had two
releases you had barker zero zero one
and you had utility
now utility is the album which most
explicitly adopts
david pierce's work specifically in the
hedonistic imperative
so you mentioned electronic dance
producers and artists in general
can be sort of the first wave of or can
perhaps
assist in paradise engineering insofar
as that will be
possible in the near to short-term
future given advancements in technology
is that sort of the explicit motivation
and framing around
those two releases of barker01 and
utility
barca 001 was
a few tracks that were taken out of the
running for the
album because they didn't sort of fit
the concept so
really only the last track was kind of
alluding to the album
and otherwise it was perhaps not sort of
thematically linked
[Music]
do
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
hopefully if people are interested in
looking more into what's behind the
music that you can lead people into
topics with the concepts so with utility
i didn't want to just keep exploring
cognitive biases and unpicking dance
music structurally
it's sort of a paradox because i guess
the headness the comparative argues that
pleasure can exist without purpose
but i really was striving for some kind
of purpose with the pleasure that i was
getting from
music that sort of emerged from reading
the hedonistic imperative
really that you can apply music to this
problem of raising the
general level of happiness up a notch
i did sort of worry that by trying to
please it wouldn't work that it would be
something that was too
sickly sweet i mean i'm pretty turned
off by pop music
and there was this sort of risk that it
would end up somewhere like that
that's it really just looking for a
higher purpose with my work in
music david do you have any reactions
well
when i encountered utility yes i was
thrilled
as you know essentially i'm a writer
writing in quite
heavy sub-academic prose and sam's work
i felt helps give people a glimpse
of our glorious future paradise
engineering
as you know the reviews were extremely
uh favorable
i'm not a an expert critic or anything
like that
i was just essentially happy and
thrilled at the thought it deserves to
be mainstream
and it's really difficult i think to
actually evoke the glorious future we're
talking about
i mean yeah i can write prose but in
some sense
music can evoke paradise better
at least for many people than pros i
think there's something
you can appreciate without cognitive
effort which your pros
at least you need to be uh able to read
it's a bit more of a passive way of
receiving music which i think is an
intrinsic
advantage it has that's that's actually
really a relief to hear because there
was just a small
fear in my mind that i was grabbing
these concepts with clumsy hands and
discrediting them
oh not at all it all came from a place
of sincere appreciation for
the sort of world that you were trying
to entice people with
when i tried to put into words what it
was that was so inspiring
i think it's that there was also a sort
of very practical kind of making lots of
notes
i've got lots of amazing one-liners
will we ever leave the biological dark
ages
or the biological domestication of
heaven there was just so many things
that
conjure up such vividly heavenly
sensations
it sort of brings me back to the
fuzziness of art and inspiration but
i hope i've tried to adopt the same
spirit of optimism
that you approached the hedonistic
imperative with
i actually don't know what your state of
mind or your approach was at the time
even but
it must have come in a bout of extreme
hopefulness
yes actually i started taking selectally
and six weeks later i wrote to the
hedonistic imperative it just gave me
just enough optimism to embark on
i mean i have fundamentally a very dark
view of darwinian life but for mainly
technical
reasons i think the future is going to
be super humanly glorious
but how do you evoke this for uh dark
darwinian minds yeah how do we get
people
excited about it i think you did a great
job it deserves to go mainstream really
the core idea i mean forget the details
the neurobabble the genetics yeah of
course it's
incredibly important but this vision of
just how
sublimely wonderful life could be
but how do we achieve full spectrum
multimedia dominance
i mean i can write it so you guys need
to team up
it's very primitive and i'm excited
where it could head
definitely all right i really like this
idea
about music showing how good the future
can be
i think that many of the ways that
people can
understand how good the future can be
comes from the best experiences they've
had in their life
now that's just a physical state of your
brain and
if something isn't physically impossible
then the only barrier to achieving and
realizing that thing is knowledge
so take all the best experiences in your
life and
if we could just understand computation
and biology in the brain
and consciousness well enough it doesn't
seem like there's any
real limits to how good and beautiful
things can get
do any of the tracks that you've done
evoke very specific visions dreams
desires or hopes
i would be sort of hesitant to make
direct links between
tracks and particular mindsets because
when i'm sitting down to make music i'm
not really thinking about any one
particular
thing rather trying to look
past things and look more about what
sort of mood
i want to put into the work any of the
tracks on the record perhaps could have
been called
paradise engineering is what i'm saying
the
names for all the tracks are sort of a
collection of the ideas that were
feeding the overall process and
the application of the names was kind of
retroactive connection making
that's probably uh disappointment to
some people but the meaning of all of
the track names is
in the whole of the record i think the
last track on the record
die hards of the darwinian order that
was a phrase that you used david to
describe people clinging to the need for
pain
in life to experience pleasure yes and
that track was not made for the record
it was made some time ago and it was
just a technical experiment to see if i
could kind of recreate a
realistic sounding band with my
synthesizers
but the label manager alex was really
keen to have this on the record
and i was kind of like oh it doesn't fit
conceptually
it has a kick drum it's kind of somber
mood and the rest of the record is
really
uplifting or trying to be and alex was
saying he liked the contrast
to the positivity of the rest of the
album felt like it needed this dose of
realism or something
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so i sort of conceded in the end but we
called it diehards of the darwinian
order because
that was what i felt like he was have
you told him this oh i told him he
definitely uh took the criticism
but as i said it's the actual joining up
of these ideas that i'd made notes on
and the tracks themselves in the end
have to be
done in a creative way sort of
retroactively but that doesn't mean to
say that
all of these concepts were not crucial
to the process of making the
record when you're starting a project
you
call it something like new track happy 2
mix 1 or something and then eventually
the sort of meaning emerges from the end
result in a way
it's just like what i've heard from
authors of best-selling books they say
you have no idea what the book is going
to be called until the end right yeah
one of the reasons i think it's so
important to stress
life based on gradients of bliss
ratcheting up hedonic
set points is that instead of me or
anyone else trying to
impose their distinctive vision of
paradise
it just allows with complications
everyone to keep most of their existing
values and preferences but just ratchets
up hedonic tone and hedonic range i mean
this is the problem with so many
traditional paradises they
involve the imposition of someone else's
values and preferences on you
i'm being overly cerebral about it now
but i think my favorite track on the
album is the first that i
would encourage people to conjure up
their
vision of paradise and the future can
potentially be like that
and be much much better
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
yeah this i think relates to the sort of
pushiness that i was feeling odds with
the music does take people to these kind
of euphoric states sometimes chemically
underwritten but it's being done in a
dogmatic and
singular way there's not much room for
personal
interpretation it's sort of everybody's
experiencing one thing
which i think there's something in these
kind of communal experiences that i'm
gonna
hopefully understand one day all right
i think some of my favorite tracks are
look how hard i've tried
on d biasing i also really like maximum
utility
and neuron collider i mean all of it is
quite good and palatable thank you the
ones that you said are some of my
personal
favorites it's also funny how some of
the least favorite tracks
or not least favorite but the ones that
i felt like didn't really do what they
set out to do
were the people's favorites hedonic
treadmill for example
i put that on the pile of didn't work
but people i was playing it to
finding things in it that i didn't
intentionally put there
really that track felt to me like stuck
on the pedonic treadmill and not sort of
managing to
push the speed up or the push the level
up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is i suppose the problem with that
there isn't a universal
pleasure center there isn't uh one size
fits all
way to these higher states you correctly
called it the hedonic treadmill some
people say the hedonistic
treadmill one professor i know calls it
the hedonistic treadmill i want to get
on that
i wouldn't mind spending all day on a
heated list
that's my kind of exercise all right
so let's pivot here into section two of
our conversation then for this section i
just like to focus on
the future in particular and exploring
the state of
dance music culture how it should evolve
and how science and technology
along with art and music can evolve into
the future
this question comes from you in
particular sam addressed to dave
i think you're curious about his
experiences in life and
if he's ever lost himself on a dance
floor or has any
special music or records that put him in
a state of bliss
very curious my musical autobiography
well some of my earliest memories is of
a wind-up
gramophone showing my age here
apparently as a five-year-old child i
used to sing on the buses
uh daisy daisy give me your answer do
i'm so crazy awful love of you
then that yeah graduating via the
military brass band
plays apparently i used to enjoy as a
small child
to pop music essentially for me
i very very uncerebral about
music i like to use it as a backdrop you
know
at its best this little tingle up one
spine one gets that it doesn't happen
very often the only thing i would say is
that
it's really important for me that music
should be happy
i know some people get into sad music
i know it's complicated but music for me
has to elicit something that's purely
good
i definitely have no problem with
exploring the sort of darker side of
human nature but
i also have come to the realization that
there's better ways to explore
the dark sides than aesthetic
stimulation
through perhaps words and ideas and
aesthetics is really at its optimum
function when it's
working towards more positive goals of
happiness
and joy and these sort of swear words in
the art world
dave you're not trying to hide your rave
warehouse days from us are you
well yeah let's just say i might not
have been entirely drug naive
with friends let's just say i was high
on life
or something but it's a long time since
i have
explored that scene but part of me still
misses it but when it comes to anything
of the art world
just as i think visual art should be
beautiful
which i mean not all serious artists
would agree
i think the whole notion is just people
find it repulsive somehow especially in
the art world like
somebody that painted a picture and then
the description reads
i just wanted it to be pretty is getting
thrown out the gallery
but what greater purpose could it really
take on
yeah maybe there's some feeling of
insecurity and
a feeling and a need to justify the work
as having meaning beyond
the sensual or something and then there
may also be like this fact contributing
to it
seeking happiness and sensual pleasure
directly in and of itself is often
counterproductive towards that goal
seeking well-being and happiness
directly usually
subverts that mission and i guess that's
just a curse of darwinian life so
perhaps those i'm just speculating here
contribute to this
cultural distaste as you're pointing out
to
joy pleasure as the goals
of art yeah we're sort of intellectually
allergic to
these kinds of ideas i think that just
seems sort of really shallow and
superficial i suppose that was kind of
my
existential fear before the album came
out that the idea that i was just
trying to make people happy would just
be seen as this shallow thing
which i don't see it as but i think the
sentiment is quite strong in the art
world
if that's quite shallow then i guess
those people are also
going to have problems with the buddha
and people like that so i wouldn't worry
about it too much i think you're on the
same
intentional ground as the buddha so
moving a little bit along here
do you guys have thoughts or opinions on
the future of aesthetics art music and
joy and
how science and technology can
contribute to that oh good heavens
one possibility will be that as
neuroscience
advances it would be possible to isolate
the molecular experience of visual
beauty
musical bliss spiritual excellence
and scientifically amplify
them so that one can essentially enjoy
musical experiences
that orders of magnitude richer than
anything that's even physiologically
feasible today i mean i can use all this
fancy language but what actually this
will
involve in terms of true transhuman and
post-human
artists the gradients of bliss
is important here such that i think we
will
retain information sensitive gradients
so we don't lose
critical sharpness discernment critical
appreciation
but nonetheless this base point for
aesthetic excellence
all experience can be super humanly
beautiful
i mean i religiously star my music
collection for a one to five but what
would a six be like
what would a hundred i like these
questions
i guess the role of the artist in
the long term future in creating
these kinds of states maybe gets pushed
out at some point by
people who are in the labs and
reprogramming the way music is or the
way that
any sort of sensory experience is
received
i wonder whether there's a place in
techno utopia for music made by humans
or whether
artists sort of just become redundant in
some way
and i'm not going to get offended if the
answer is bye-bye
i'd be interested in just making a few
points about the evolutionary
perspective before we get into the
future
of ape artists or mammalian artists
it just seems like some kind of happy
cosmic accident that for
the vibration of air human beings have
developed a
sensory appreciation of information and
structure
embedded in that medium and i think
we're
quite lucky as a species the music and
musical appreciation is
embedded in the software of human
genetics
such that we can appreciate and create
and share musical moments
now with genetic engineering and more
ambitious paradise engineering i think
it would be beautiful to
expand the modalities for which
artistic or aesthetic or the
appreciation of beauty can be
experienced
music is one clear way of having
aesthetic appreciation
and joy visual art is another one
and people do derive a lot of
satisfaction from touch
perhaps that could be more information
structured in the ways that music and
art are and
there might be a way of changing what it
means to be an intelligent thing such
that there can be
just an expansion of art appreciation
across all of our
essential modalities and even into
central modalities which
don't exist yet so the nature of
transhuman and post-human art
just leaves me floundering yeah it seems
useful here just to reflect on how happy
of an accident art is
as we begin to evolve and we can get
into say ai here
ai and machine learning is likely
to be able to have very very good models
of
say our musical preferences within the
next few years i mean they're somewhat
already very good at it it'll continue
to get better
and then we have fairly rudimental
algorithms which can
produce music and if we just extrapolate
out into the future
eventually artificial intelligence
systems will be able to
produce music better than any human so
in that world what is the role of the
human artist
i guess i'm not sure i'm also completely
not sure
but i feel like it's probably gonna
happen in
my lifetime that these technologies get
to a point that they
actually do serve the purpose that uh
because at the moment there is ai
software that can create
unique compositions but it does so by
looking at an archive of music with ava
it's
bach and beethoven mozart and then it
reinterprets all of the
codes that are embedded in that and uses
that to make new stuff and it sounds
just like a composer quoting and
convincing
so considering this is going to get
better and better
i'm pretty confident that we'll have a
system that will
be able to create music to a person's
specific taste and having not
experienced music that would say look at
my music library
and then start making things that i
might like i can't say how i feel about
that but let's say if it worked and it
did actually
surprise me and i was feeling like
humans can't make this kind of
sensation in me this is a level above in
a way
somebody that doesn't like the vagueness
of the creative process
this really appeals somehow
but the way that things are used and the
way that our attention is sort of a
resource that gets
manipulated i don't know whether we have
an incredible technology
once again in the wrong hands and it's
just going to be
turned into a mind control these kind of
things would be
put to use for nefarious purposes i
don't feel the technology i feel what
we in our unmodified state might do with
it
yes i wonder when the last professional
musician will retire having been
eclipsed by
ai i mean in some sense we are i think
stepping stones to something better
i don't know when the last philosophers
will be pensioned off
hard problem of mind solved announced in
nature
nobel prize beckoned you know
distinguished philosophers of mind
announce
their intention to retire hard to
imagine
but yeah one does suppose that ai will
be creating
work of ever greater excellence tailored
to the individual
i think the evolutionary roots
of aesthetic appreciation are very very
deep
but yeah it can of course sound very
disrespectful to artists saying that
ai could replace artists but
mathematicians
and scientists are probably going to be
everyone's getting replaced
it's maybe a similar step to when
portrait
painters when the camera was threatening
their line of work
and can press a button in an instant do
what would have taken for several days
i sort of am cautiously looking forward
to
more intelligent assistance in the
production of music but if we did live
in a world where
there wasn't any struggles to express or
any
wrongs to write any flaws in our
character to
un-pick then i would struggle to find
anything
other than the sort of basic pleasure of
the action of making music
i wouldn't really feel any reason to
share what i
made in a sense i think there's a sort
of moral
social purpose that's embedded within
music if you want to
grasp it i think if ai is
implemented with that same moral ethical
purpose then
in a way we should treat it as any other
task
that comes to be automated or extremely
simplified
in some way we should embrace the
relaxation of our workload in a way
and there's nothing to say that we
couldn't just continue to make music if
it brought us pleasure
i think distinguishing between these two
things of making music and sharing it
was an important discovery for me
the process of making a piece of music
if it was entirely
pleasurable but then you treat the
experience like it was a failure because
it didn't reach enough people or you
didn't get the response or the boost to
your ego that you were
searching from it then it's your
remembering self overriding you are
experiencing self in a way
or your expectations get in the way of
your
enjoyment of the process so
if there was no purpose to it anymore i
might still make it for my own pleasure
but
i like to think i'd be happy that a
world that didn't require music was
already a better place i like to think
that i wouldn't be upset with my
uh redundancy with my p45 from david
pearce
oh no with a neurochip you see
your creative capacitors could be
massively augmented you'd have
narrow super intelligence on a chip now
in one sense i don't think classical
digital
computers are going to wake up and
become conscious so they're never
actually going to be able to
experience music or art or anything like
this so in that sense they will
remain tools but tools that one can
actually incorporate within oneself so
they become part of you friendly flag
there that
many people who've been on this podcast
disagree with that point
but yeah fair enough david
so i mean it seems that there are like
maybe three options one
is as you mentioned sam to find joy and
beauty in more things and to sort of let
go
of the need for meaning and joy to come
from
not being something that is redundant
once human beings
are made obsolete or redundant
it's quite sad for us because we drive
much of our meaning and
thanks a lot evolution from
accomplishing things and
being relevant so the two paths here
are seems like reaching some kind of
spiritual evolution such that we're okay
with being redundant
or being okay with passing away
as a species and allowing our
descendants to proliferate
or the last one would be to like change
what it means to be human
such that by merging or by evolution we
somehow remained relevant to the
progress of civilization
so i don't know which one it will be but
we'll see i think
the exciting one for me is where we can
harness the advances
in technology in a conscious way to
positive ends to
greater net well-being in society
maybe i'm hooked on the old ideals but i
do think
a sense of purpose in your pleasure
elevates the sensation
somewhat i think human brains on mdma
would disagree with that
[Laughter]
yeah so you've obviously also reflected
on an experience like that after the
event
and come to the conclusion that there
wasn't perhaps
much concrete meaning to your experience
but it was
joyful and real and vivid and you don't
want to focus too much on the fact that
it was
mostly just you jumping up and down on a
dance floor and
so i i'm definitely familiar with the
pleasure of
essentially meaningless euphoria
i'll say the very least it's interesting
to think about
yeah in reading a lot about the nature
of happiness and
the general consensus there being that
happiness is sort of
a balance of pleasure and purpose the
idea that
maybe you don't need the purpose is
worth exploring i think at least
we do have this term empty hedonism but
one thing that's striking is that as
one for whatever reason or explanation
gets happier and happier
everything seems more intensely
meaningful
there are pathological forms like mania
or hypermania where it leads to
grandiosity
messianic delusions even theo mania and
thinking one is
god but it's possible to have much more
benign
versions and in practice i think when
life is based on radiance of bliss
eventually superhuman bliss this will
entail superhuman meaning and
significance
and essentially we've got a choice i
mean we can either have
pure bliss or one could have a
combination
of bliss and hyper motivation and one
will be able to tweak the dials
this is all such deliciously appealing
language as someone who's
spending a lot of their time tweaking
dials
this may or may not be the appropriate
time to ask but tell me about what
future projects have you
planned i'm still very much exploring
the potential of music as a increase of
well-being and i think it's sort of
leading me in interesting
directions at present i'm sort of
in another crossroads i feel
the general drive to realize these sort
of
higher functions of music is still a
driving force
i'm starting to look at what is natural
in music and what is learned and like
you say there is this long history of
the way that we appreciate
sound that's linked to all kinds of
repetitive experiences that our
ancestors had and
there's other aspects to sound
production
that are also very old like use of
reverb is
connected to our experiences sort of
cavemen dwelling in
these kind of reverberant spaces and
these are kind of sacred spaces for
early humans and so this
feeling of when you walk into a
cathedral for example this otherworldly
experience
that comes from the acoustics is i think
somehow
deeply tied to this historical situation
of
seeking shelter in caves and then caves
having a bigger significance in the
lives of
early humans there's a realization i
suppose that what we're
experiencing that relates to music is
rhythm tone and tumblr noise
you know if you just sort of pay
attention to your background noise
the things that you're most familiar
with are actually not very musical
and you don't really find harmony in
nature very much
so i'm sort of forming some
ideas around what parts of music and
our response to music uh cultural and
what a natural is a sort of a strange
word to apply but
our sort of harmonic language is a
technical construction
and rhythm is something we have a much
deeper connection with
through our lives that's defined by
rhythms of
planets and that dividing our time into
smaller and smaller ratios down to
heartbeats and breathing
so we're sort of experiencing a really
complex polyrhythmic
silence form of music i suppose
so i'm separating these two concepts of
rhythm and
harmony and trying to get to the bottom
of their function and
goal of elevating bliss and happiness
i guess looking at what the tools i'm
using
are and what their role could be if that
makes any sense
in some sense this sounds weird i think
insofar as this possible
one does have a duty to take care of
oneself
and if one can give happiness to others
not least by music in that sense one can
be
a more effective altruist in some sense
perhaps one feels
ethically ought to want to be working 12
14 hours a day
to make the world a better place but
equally
we all have our design limitations and
just being able to relax and either as a
consumer of music or if one is a creator
of music that has a valuable role too
it really does everyone needs to take
care of one's own mental health to be
able to help others
i feel like the kind of under the bonnet
tinkering that in some way needs to
happen
for us to really make use of these new
technologies we need to
do something about human nature i feel
like we're
a bit further away from those sort of
realities than we are with the
technological side so
i think there needs to be a sort of
emergency measures
in some way to improve human nature
through the old-fashioned
social cultural nudges perhaps as a stop
gap until we can really
roll our sleeves up and change human
nature on a molecular level
yeah i think we might need both all the
kind of environmental
social political reform together with a
biological genetic
biohappiness revolution i would love to
be able to
you know a hundred year plan group to
get rid of suffering replace it with
gradients of bliss paradise engineering
in practice i feel the story of
darwinian life still has several
centuries
to go i hope i'm too pessimistic some of
my
transhumanists colleagues the
intelligence explosion or a
complete kurtz finally infusion of
humans in our machines
but we shall see so david
sam and i and everyone else loves your
pros so much could you just kind of go
off here and
muster your best pros to give us some
thoughts as beautiful as sunsets for how
good a future of music and art
and gradients of intelligent bliss will
be i'm afraid put eloquence on hold but
yeah just try
for a moment to remember your most
precious beautiful sublime experience in
your life whatever it was
it may or may not be suitable for public
consumption
and just try to hold it briefly imagine
if life could be like that only far
far better all the time and with no
nasty side effects no adverse
social consequences it is going to be
possible to build
this kind of super civilization
based on gradients of bliss
and be over ambitious needless to say if
anything i have
written unfortunately you need to wade
through all manner of fluff
but as i said i'm really uh thrilled and
chuffed with utility and so
anything else is just veganizing on the
cake
beautiful i'm really uh like i say super
relieved that it was
taken as such it was really like a
reconfiguring of my approach and my
involvement with the thing that i've
sort of
given my life to thus far and a sort of
a clarification
of the purpose and aside from anything
else it just put me in a really
perfect mindset for addressing mental
obstacles in the way of
my own happiness but then once you get
that you sort of feel
like sharing it with other people so i
think
it started off a very positive process
in my thoughts
which sort of manifested in the work i
was doing so
extremely grateful for your generosity
and lending these ideas i hope actually
just that people
scratch the surface a little bit and
maybe plug some of the terms into a
search engine and
got kind of lost in the world of utopia
a little bit that was really the main
reason for putting these references in
and pushing people in that direction
well you've given people a lot of
pleasure which is fantastic
and certainly i'd personally rather be
thought of as
associated with paradise engineering and
gradients of bliss rather than a
depressive gloomy negative utilitarian
yeah there's a real dark side to the
idea
i think the thing i read after the
hedonistic imperative was
some of les knights writing about
voluntary human extinction
movement i honestly don't know if he'd
be classified as the utilitarian but the
sort of ecocentric
utilitarianism which you sort of
endorse through including the animal
kingdom in your
manifesto and there's a sort of a
growing appreciation for
this kind of antenatal sentiment yes
anti-natalism
seems to be growing but i don't think
it's ever going to be
dominant the only way to get rid of
suffering and ensure
high quality of life for all sentient
beings is going to be
essentially get to the heart of the
problem to rewrite ourselves i did
actually do an antenatalist podcast
the other week but i'm only a soft
anti-natalist because there's always
going to be
selection pressure in in favor of a
predisposition to go forth and
multiply one needs to build alliances
with
fanatical life lovers even if when one
contemplates the state of the world one
has some rather dark thoughts
yeah all right so is there any questions
or things
we haven't touched on that you guys
would like to talk about
no i just really wanted to thank you to
lucas for
organizing this you've got a quite a
diverse
range of podcasts now and sam
i'm honored thank you very much really
happy this has gone well
yeah david really it's been my pleasure
and really appreciate
your time and acceptance of uh how i've
sort of handled your ideas
i feel really happy that i was able to
connect you guys and
i also think that both of you guys make
the world more beautiful by your work
and presence and for that i
am grateful and appreciative and also
very much enjoy and take inspiration
from both of your work
so keep on doing what you're doing
thanks lucas thank you
really thank you lucas very much
appreciated
i hope that you've enjoyed the
conversation portion of this podcast
now i am happy to introduce the guest
mix
by barker
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
get out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you